[Music]
[Applause]
John you've been on the road for too
long you're losing it John mr. devil I
have a body for you mr. temple you in
here Devils not easy man to get to
[Music]
well we killed the devil okay that was
easy that was pretty easy
um now oh dang well this is dirty Rd
chapter 18 we kind of did a whole
episodes worth a little too quickly no I
I say as we are trying to kill the devil
we did but there are still demons all
about the land so I think we should
become like a an exorcist or maybe more
in line with like John Constantine oh
hell yeah
taking care of business so I have picked
out an outfit for us to try on all right
I think that I think will suit our new
role as exorcists last slash demon
hunter a demon hunt a deep word demon
hunter that's what we are oh there is
dirty Rd demon hunter dirty Rd demon
hunter but how do we know if people have
the earth if they're actually a demon
because right I imagine they hide I
think the signs are [ __ ] oh we're okay
you know this one had doesn't have a
name I think the signs of a demon
correlate to like bad attitude mmm or
maybe if you like walk into their shop
and they flinch that's definitely better
than right that's definitely a sign of
possess yeah that's possession for sure
but as a demon hunter woulld will do the
interrogation and we'll make we'll make
a call on whether there is a
demon hi Tod demon undo already yeah
well we'll make a call if there's a
demon hiding behind human scanner come
on
get clear all right go on
horse ain't never gonna like you though
no let me see you again
I heard that clear sign of the devil
the devil is in that man watching you in
person that looks like a demon giving
supplies to other demons let's have a
chat
yeah why don't we have a little friends
in companionship so if they mentioned
the devil yep that's a good sign or
probably anything like it got anything
like that anything religious there yeah
probably
I agree there there a demon or they're
possessed if they like clip through
trees or anything like that they're
clearly using devil magic to go through
phase through objects good point if they
twitch can we see them yep any sign of
like skittish behavior definitely yep
I mean with the Pinkertons with
O'Driscoll's the Damned Oh Driscoll's
the last thing we need are demons
running bail
I agree yeah I have an idea oh is this
some like next-level demon hunter oh
yeah bait
you're gonna alert oh oh this is amazing
lure out the other demons with a demon
precisely
oh I think he's dead well it's still a
win you know dead demon yeah we still
won technically like the way you're
thinking there we'll have to find
ourselves another I like how you still
didn't give them shoes yeah forgot to
mention that yeah very intentional later
oh this is that I don't even think I
should let him live do you hear he
cursed me to hell
yeah as I said he said it earlier - only
good demon is a dead demon seems okay
those are demon demon hunter goggles oh
ho that's a steak I think I think it is
oh dude I say you follow this guy
antagonize him
nope that's a demon Arendt oh god oh god
ever should we take him to the law
[Laughter]
[Music]
damnit you're coming to jail let's bring
this demon back inside let's put him in
a jail cell that's good enough
Oh who's in that jail cell what do you
do is possessed I need to know who we
have to find we got to find out so why
don't you shoot near one of them and
whoever flinches first is the demon guy
that was exactly at the same time they
seemed like which wins yeah I don't know
I think it's the one on the left I think
it's this guy I think that's fine o
demon
all right that's my that's my new
favorite thick paint paint that face
with bullets
oh shoot his balls off
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it's gotta be possessed he's like not
even a the rest of shares sheriff badges
and since one guy runs in this exact
same spot one bullet to the head yep I
think you got him dirty Artie be cool
right on dad demon Raton Oh through all
those people up there we're on the to
the right on the balcony of the building
[Laughter]
the demon hunter hunters are coming so
you just burn the place and leave yeah
let's go burn the mayor's house
[Music]
yeah keep them coming demons
Oh probably demon oh there's a perfect
horse for I know yeah demon hunt there
it is
find a stable and I go well Howard the
horse go not back there oh yeah it's
perfect
see if they find me god damn it I found
my hiding spot this is such a mess
there's so many things oh god gain some
speed horses back to on foot
well they don't do it well we racked up
quite a body count already yeah
definitely
I mean demon count I guess right right
yeah yeah right demons we were only
killing the demons maybe that one guy
was that one guy probably wasn't who I
threw the fire bottle at yeah maybe
well I think he was in cahoots with the
demons you know yes you see what he was
carrying it was probably like molten
lava or something I don't know that's
what the devil likes right yeah I think
so
he was a demon supporter yeah exactly
damn this horse is sick never mind like
a speed bump we're just kidding I won't
put you again I swear horse runs whoo
hey whistles for her to come back
apologize man
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
t-rex oh you broke you broken the horse
and now you don't even want it this is
the the first dirty Rd horse is actually
worked for we have to cherish this horse
we have to come with a good name we'll
take it to the stable and then we'll
load up a different timeline it'll be
completely gone we'll forget about him
yep
yeah earlier I liked how we liked how
about like awesome like all-black
looking horse and then we had it for
about 5 seconds even you thought about
bringing it to the stables
there's quite the posse falling Rob
we've really pissed them off this time
yeah well there goes that horse no he oh
that's dead they're just straight-up
died oh it's dead dead I like one ticket
of Van Horn please hello you hear all
that out there
oh so weird don't know who dad could
have been hit demons are here they're
around me Park stop wasting my time
nice knowing you demon
yeah look at rain take it easy those
gunshots crazy right
[Music]
home of the deep we're in now let's do
some light interrogation Oh Oh what's in
there
how about you stop following me don't
you say a word his office
oh my god oh my god this guy no the guy
who's preaching it's easy this guy's dad
yeah oh he's a scientist we'll deal with
them I have a plan
I have a plan oh I see where you re
going with this all right well I didn't
think they'd care if I came in here
oh you're dead oh god dude
eat some food I was trying to get on the
roof and then I was gonna snipe take
care of them with my demon rifle but it
didn't quite work
yeah now it's time for show us your RTE
where you guys send in your own
Arthur Morgan creations up first
this is Beatles JP gr and he said this
is clean bar clean clean party he said
this is clean arty with maximum beard
length we don't see too many clean
Artie's so I was like yeah looks pretty
good yeah yeah and our our recent
stomping ground yep this one's really
good this is from doom Zilla dude the
clip art I like can't get over how
awesome some of these like like pieces
of art have been in that I love it yeah
this is so cool
I love all the cans of being scattered
on I love how he's naked and without
genitals yeah yeah I like this one
namely that perfect perfect tail I know
look the Sun backlighting it and
everything it's like looks like it's
kicking up snow on its tail you know
then the north of the map is one place
we haven't been too much with dirty art
yeah we should check it out maybe that's
what we should do next episode that's a
pretty sweet looking photo this is from
feature creature he actually sent us a
video but because of copyright we don't
want to risk it and put it in here but
you can seek that out your knees did but
he did send some photos too and a little
different take on Artie he looks like he
doesn't really know that there's a kid
like he doesn't know how cameras work
what yeah it also know I think that
reminds me of like Matt Damon from
Elysium oh I did not see this
[Laughter]
hashtag and we were in tag that I saw it
loads like yeah this is this is going in
that's going in that is some some dark
deep dirty already ties right there
that's awesome I saw this one too look
at it this is I guess online mode is I
think like my character also has yeah
this is pretty good it's pretty good
very dirty like her face is almost yeah
nice little collage of 18:47 or Arthur
Morgan is agent 47 which is pretty good
I'd say so good you really Kelly's
taking a bath too yeah you can really
make them look like I'm like I know it
looks pretty good looks pretty dope and
then in the disguise of course often
right yeah so good and those are all the
photos we have for show us you're
already if you didn't notice this is
what this week was a little bit slimmer
and that's because we're recording early
because I'm gonna be gone next week so
we're trying to get an extra episode in
there and then Joey's gonna take over
the week after and then I'll be back
after that right just for one episode
then well thank you guys so much for
watching and thank you for submitting
your show us your artis we'll see y'all
next week
you